and I listened to with great interest to
what my good friend Terris was nick has
set on this regard I must say that I
belonged to a little bit different
school of thought about the place and
role of Ukraine and what Poland and the
United States are expecting from Ukraine
to play in united Europe from my point
of view poland was and is the most
consistent supporter of ukraine in
european structures and i myself was a
witness in a different conferences when
President Kwasniewski was very
convincingly trying to convince the
partners from the Western European
countries from the United States to pay
more attention to Ukraine it was the
Polish foreign ministry which has
introduced at the beginning of the year
two thousand three if I'm not mistaken
there to my mind the most favorable
towards Ukraine's interest concept of
the instant dimension of the enlarged
European Union unfortunately this
concept hasn't become the basis of the
final version of the Eastern dimension
policy of the European Union but to my
mind this was the best well alternative
for the alternative prepared by the
European Commission as to the
relationship between the enlarged
European Union and Ukraine and as to the
role of Poland Ukraine and European
Union I don't think that it is in the
interest of the European Union to keep
Ukraine end of the United States and
even more from Poland to keep Ukraine as
a as a buffer zone between Russia and
the enlarged European Union and NATO to
my mind it is equally important for
Poland to have Ukraine inseparable part
of both native
and European Union and in such a manner
too well to to have a kind of buffer if
by one say instead of keeping Ukraine
outside of both European Union and NATO
Ukraine is very potentially very strong
a partner for both NATO and European
Union to ignore let me say a few words
about the how of both countries are
doing economically well from my point of
view Ukraine and Poland are very good
heartless economic partners and the
economy and the traitor nor is being
developed rather actively last year our
trade reached the figure of more than
two billion u.s. dollars and during last
year alone they trade between our
countries increased by forty percent
which is one of the most impressive and
biggest figure of the increase in trade
turnover Ukraine had last year with
other partners so the perspective is to
have our trade well this car this year
and perhaps next year close to two point
seven three billion you know US dollars
we have a very good project Odessa Robin
plots pipeline and finally the
discussions between both countries has
ended and we have entered the the
pragmatic practical stage in in the
realization of this project which would
be subtly for the benefit of both